Ukraine claims to have liberated 6 000
square kilometers of its own territory
[Music]
so what does this tell us about the
offensive and the nature of the war up
to this point
so far the Ukrainian offensive has had
the effect of making the Russia's
withdrawal from the whole of the khakive
oblast the whole of the kharkiv region
and that opens up the area to the south
of donbass which is what President Putin
said he must take as as his minimum
requirement in this war so the
ukrainians are now certainly in that
part of the uh the front able to dictate
terms
and they can decide where they want to
go next with their offensive and then
down in the southwest in Kirsten they
are actually pushing very hard in order
to retake that City that might be a
tougher job but I suspect that they will
take it eventually because they're
moving in on it from three different
sides
and weapons were key to this offensive
partly because they allow the ukrainians
to run this battle as if it was a
western Army so it used the long-range
weapons the accurate precise weapons
that the West had given it in order to
Target Russian rare areas the ammunition
dumps the headquarters the centers of
logistics some of the bridges that will
be critical to them and they pin Russian
forces in place making it very difficult
for them to move around and almost
impossible for them to get
reinforcements before they began the
battle and then when the battle began
they were able to use not so much
Western tanks but Western protected
Mobility all of the various armored
vehicles that are necessary to move
troops around a battlefield quickly and
safely
one of the interesting points about this
is that whereas the Russians use lots of
vehicles with tracks on track vehicles
they're very heavy the vehicles that the
ukrainians were using tended to be
wheeled Vehicles they've got some track
vehicles and tanks and so on but a lot
of their Mobility was based on wheeled
Vehicles which are faster and more
mobile and more agile and so they've
gone for Speed in this offensive and it
seems to have paid off using Western
methods Western training and quite a lot
of Western Equipment
this offensive has exposed the fragility
the brittleness of Russia's military
Machinery because their troops are not
especially well motivated they don't
seem to be very well trained or very
well supplied and the speed at which
they have collapsed they haven't just
withdrawn they have collapsed the
officer seems to too many officers seem
to run away and when the officer runs
away the men just disappear why should
they stay if the officer is not prepared
to to stay and take risks and the as we
were years of neglect of Russian forces
have become pretty clear and it isn't
just the scratch forces who seem to have
disintegrated the first guards tank Army
seems to have disintegrated the first
guard's tank arm is one of their elite
units it's one of their best units and
yet it's it seemed to withdrawn in a
hurry leaving most of its tanks behind
if if a guard's tank regiment doesn't
have its tanks it doesn't have anything
um it's the same seems to happen to the
fourth guards tank regiment and so this
has been a real humiliation not just for
the militias and the chechens and the
Wagner
private military companies who are
working for the Russians this has been
humiliation to some of the elite
regiments of the Russian army and they
haven't had anything as bad as this on
an open Battlefield they haven't lost on
an open Battlefield like this since
December 1942.
I don't think it's true to say that the
operation in the southwest in Kirsten
was all a decoy to draw Russian forces
away from the parking region although it
did have that effect all the evidence is
that the ukrainians fully intend to
conduct a true prong defensive and that
is indeed what they're doing the New
York Times has recently reported that
this offensive this two-pronged
defensive was being wargamed out by
British American and Ukrainian officers
together to make sure that they thought
that it was feasible and they could do
it and the the offensive in person is
strategically more important than the
offense the offensive up in kharkiv in
the Northeast because Kirsten is a more
important city and if they get control
back of Kirsten and that Coastline then
they can threaten all of Russian
occupied Crimea which will be a major
strategic advantage to Kiev
of course it's one thing to attack an
area an army then has to hold it but in
this case the ukrainians are liberating
their own territory they don't have any
problems of domestic order when they
move on The Villages and towns are
delighted to see them and only too happy
to get themselves back on their feet
after Russian occupation so the
ukrainians have the benefit of being
able to keep on moving forward with just
administrators and civilians coming in
to try to sort out the mess that
whatever was was left by the Russians
who retreated when you're invading a
foreign country that doesn't want you
there for every town and Village that
you take you've got to leave more troops
behind so your offensive gets thinner
and thinner the more territory you
conquer when you're re-conquering your
own country you don't have to leave
anybody behind and so the ukrainians
shouldn't have any problem in actually
holding on to the territory they have
taken as long as they've got the right
equipment and follow-on numbers just to
as it will solidify the lines of
communication not the battle lines but
there logistical communication lines
they need to keep those safe just in
case the Russians try a counter-attack
when we think about what happens next
on the Ukrainian side they get to make
the next set of decisions the momentum
is with them they're moving forward they
can decide if they want to end this
offensive quite soon or whether they
want to try to go for liberating more
territory in the dombas or even more
territory further south somewhere south
of zaparisia even as far down as marupol
or litepol on the coast they get to
choose
for the Russians what happens next is
that they have to buy time they're going
backwards there's no natural line that
they can stop at so they need to dig in
somewhere and wait for the winter
and then what happens next is that there
will almost certainly be a major
strategic offensive by the Russians
probably early next year and that may be
another big turning point in the war one
thing we're all certain about is that
President Putin will not be giving up
although he can't do very much about
these Battlefield losses in the short
term he will try to keep Ukraine Under
Pressure probably by attacking the
civilian population by attacking the
critical National infrastructure Maybe
by a series of cyber attacks he will up
the ante for what this whole war is
about and undoubtedly he will try to do
something that takes Everybody by
surprise and so he'll respond to this
battlefield reversal not by giving up
but by actually taking the war in a
different direction and both Ukraine and
the Western backers of Ukraine will have
to be ready